it would have an impact on society in
the sense of how we view ourselves
yeah there are many different aspects
how we view our place
in the universe you know and uh our
aspirations for space
if there are others out there if there
is a smarter kid on the block and by the
way most stars formed billions of years
before the sun and therefore they may
have had civilizations like us
billions of years before us so we're
arriving relatively late to the game you
know the way i see it is you know we are
born into this world
uh just like actors that are put on a
stage without a script we don't know
what the play is about
so the first thing to check is whether
there are other actors out there perhaps
they know what's going on because they
have been around for a while
so that's what like searching for
another kid on the block finding whether
they're smarter kids and
you know most likely there were
civilizations that died by now
but we can find relics technological
relics they sent out to space just like
we send
voyager 1 voyager 2 no horizons and so
forth so it's a very natural to me again
it's a common sense
to
invest in the search for such things
i call it space archaeology you know
monitoring for example with the camera
every object that comes into the solar
system from outside that gets close to
earth and and checking it you know
checking whether it's artificial or
natural by a close-up photograph
because a picture is worth a thousand
words and in my case a picture is worth
66 000 was the number of words in my
book
so i think it's very natural to do this
search and invest at least the same
amount of money we invest in the search
for dark matter which is also a search
in the dark you know we don't know what
the dark matter is why not invest
hundreds of millions of dollars or
even a billion dollars that's what we
invested in in ligo
to me it sounds like a straightforward
thing to do a very common sensical thing
to do
but somehow my view is not
dominant
they say not only that but the
discussion is being ridiculed
and moreover the community doesn't like
me saying that
uh even though that's the reality of the
situation
hmm when i hear that what i'm wondering
is is there a way to monetize the search
for aliens
because then you can get the private
industry the private sector definitely
definitely and then number two what do
you think about elon musk's mission to
mars okay so those are two questions
privatizing the search for aliens and
then
elon musk definitely i think um if there
are individuals interested in the search
i have some
good ideas about how to do space
archaeology how to examine
interstellar objects that enter the
solar system and come close to earth and
take a photograph of them and you know
that that could be
a a new frontier in in astronomy that
there was never pursued and
it's
simply because
just a few years ago we discovered the
first intestinal object
so right now you know we have our eyes
open it's
it's a wake-up call for us and
i would be glad to discuss with a
wealthy individuals what can be done to
to advance this frontier i think it
would be a very exciting frontier even
more exciting than gravitational wave
astrophysics
uh or the search for dark matter
and then it could be
you know it could be the most important
discovery that humanity ever made if we
find conclusive evidence
for alien technology floating in space
so given that i think we should
definitely
pursue it
with the private sector because that is
completely independent and is known for
its innovation you know because
uh there are very wealthy individuals
that became wealthy as a result of
taking risks and you know innovating in
the technological sector so i think
it would be
fantastic to open up new scientific
frontiers
uh
that they they can pursue with their
wealth
um the second question
about going to mars i think one aspect
of that that was not explored enough and
should should be explored before we
go on that ship that brings us to mars
is um the health concern you know they
if
down here on earth we are protected by
the earth's magnetic field from very
energetic particles cosmic rays
uh and by the atmosphere of the earth uh
and
the environment of the space station
floating just hovering above earth is
also relatively protected but if you go
to mars and you spend a year
actually a significant fraction of
your brain cells can be damaged
as a result of energetic particles
going through the helmet i mean you
can't
you you have to
be in a cave underground or to have some
special
shielding around you to be protected and
there was not enough attention given to
that and i think that should be
addressed because we don't want them it
to be a one-way trip where after a year
everyone that goes there dies